sonst lässt und auf dem bock drauf
gefallen der runtergefallen und dann
mehr lava hochbekommen hey diamant
kostenlos oder hinten ist eine kiste hey
ich doch dann bricht auch als ziemliche
kiste öffnet fragezeichen
zwei freunde und herzlich willkommen
zurück zu dingsbums hierzu fit bist
megaprojekt blabla das ist einfach aus
dem grund was habe ich einige aus dem
grund wir sind die jedenfalls wieder
zurück wir sind hier weiterhin vor
dieser komischen landschaft und
versuchen hier immer noch zweifelhaften
eine höhle zu finden face camps auch
wieder mit am start aber muss ich gerade
nicht reingucken weil ich einfach gerade
nicht ob ich ihnen hülle finde da ist
eine hürde kommen
da ist auf jeden fall auch schon mal
kupfer sonst sehe ich überall november
am rand und amber ist ja für kraft bei
tomcraft wurde mir übrigens auch noch
eine mail geschrieben von namen habe ich
gerade vergessen aber auf jeden fall mit
sehr sehr vielen informationen zu sehr
unterschiedlichen modifikationen zu
tomcraft zu ganz ganz unterschiedlichen
sachen werde ich auf jeden fall später
mal reingucken
allerdings ist jetzt meine höhle und wir
brauchen ja eine menge kupfer deswegen
sind wir komplett richtig und ja wie
schon versprochen wir packen uns jetzt
hier den eisen ranisch an
und hier ist eine richtige kupfer quelle
das ist geil und also noch reisen mit
drin wir brauchen ja kupfer
hauptsächlich nur für die copper cape
ist welcher gar nicht losgegangen weil
ich ja letztens schon relativ viel
fahren war ich könnte auch einfach mal
strip meinen gehen was haltet ihr davon
schreibt das einfach mal die kommentare
ich finds tripwire übels langweilig
einfach so zuschauer weil derjenige
spieler dann einfach nur rum läuft und
quasi
ab dort halt das finde ich ein bisschen
hässlich feiere ich jetzt nicht so
so warte ich auch noch zusätzlich auch
noch so jetzt habe ich auf jeden fall
schon mal das wasser gestoppt wir
müssten kupfer finden leute wie ich habe
erst 26 kupfer ist auf jeden fall eine
menge schon mal muss man schon sagen
kupfer 26 schon gut kann man dann auf
jedenfalls 52 kupfer machen mit major
blabla mitstreiter hab ich denn
überhaupt schon weiß ich gar nicht sonst
gehe ich einmal wieder zu kämpfen bei
der mehr erlaubt das jetzt beim machen
darf sehr sehr nett und sehr sozial von
kef werde ich dann auch darauf
zurückkommen muss ich nur oh ich liebe
solche räumen wollen was man dann immer
nie wo man hingehen soll
da geht es wieder nach draußen da liegt
übrigens noch kupfer hier und es wird
glaube ich nicht gerade draußen jahr
wird es dass diese leuchtenden ärzte ihn
wie treten in höhlen zu wenig ärzte
monster auf woanders allerdings krass
fiel vor dass das uran ihm glaube ich
doch glatt gewesen oder ja uranium ohr
könnte ich mir dann auch ein kraftwerk
bauen verdiener allerdings schon
deswegen ist er relativ langweilig ich
bleib einfach beim einem solarpanel da
bin ich momentan dran am fahren
ich habe allerdings jetzt zurzeit auch
richtig bock auf dieses projekt einfach
weil man auch langsam und zeitnah sage
ich mal voran kommt und immer mehr
schaffen kann ja ich weiß da oben ist
überall noch kohle aber ich bin ja nicht
auf dem weg auf der suche nach kohle
sondern er so nach eisen habe ich zwar
schon genug aber feiern kann man nie
genug von kriegen und kopper kann man
auch nie genug von kriegen weil ich
koche cable echt für alles einfach
brauche und ich weiß nicht was klappt
einfach voll viele gänge aussieht möchte
nun immer tiefer und tiefer weil ich
eventuell ja dann auch mal einen kleinen
diamant vorrat findet vielleicht da ist
noch mehr koffer koffer kopper wien
koffer koffer kohle da geht noch weiter
jedoch nicht
egal geil auf jeden fall ja ich weiß
aber noch reisen
ich mache mir schon zu ja ich weiß ist
das war so als wenn ihr so denken würde
jahren
der nimmt dass er ähnlich alles mit nur
es ist halt wirklich damals oft
vorgekommen dass wenn man mit erz vorbei
gelaufen ist was man nicht braucht und
dann kommt neue zuschauer zu hören du
hast das übersehen
es ist hat immer gen er fällt dann
einfach nicht eingeweiht waren und dann
haben sie um gemeckert obwohl egal da
wir auf jeden fall noch grüner sagt hier
war das glaube ich oder weil das buch an
ihm nicht auf das lacrimosa 4
wir haben kupfer wir haben die menge
kupfer das ist schön
wir brauchen auch eine menge auf jeden
fall gut dass wir es finden schön
gefällt mir so hier ist noch was ist das
lied glaube ich oder es ist liegt mithin
sind ist auch gebrauchen auch für was
braucht man ein lied das war das erste
mal verwendet für war dass die batterie
ja das war die batterie dafür preisen
runter mit der schaufel ist echt scheiße
auf das eisen wir brauchen kupfer opfer
mit schon stack ich weiß nicht aber wir
haben auf jeden fall schon eine menge
kupfer das ist folge eigentlich könnten
uns direkt wieder verziehen durchdachten
wir suchen wenn ich doch jetzt schon
hier drinnen bin kann man ja mal gucken
was wir sonst noch so ist das bringt
noch kohle kohle kann man auch mal so
ein bisschen mitnehmen kohle macht man
wieder zu kohl das den mann dann wieder
für das solarpanel benötigt von daher
ich habe zwei nicht genug aber ich werde
auch dieses solarpanel sondern machen
sie sich einfach mal wie viel hat zieht
eigentlich so ein medium
ach das sind 88 low voltage wollen mich
verarschen das heißt 8 macht das heißt
64 solarpanel und noch hier das hier
dieses inserat blabla das besser als
normal kupfer schreibt meine kommentare
ist dieses in the late cable gucken
einfach ganz kurz cable
da ist dieses cable besser als dieses
cable weil das ist ja einfach zu
goldbarren und 4 davon
das ist kupfer und 6 davon also ins alte
gold cable
ist der unterschied ja das ist schon
einzelnen noch ein ich das besser ist
das besser als kupfer caicos inseln
tippt gold cable besser als kopper cable
schreibt mir das doch mal in die
kommentar ich weiß glasfaser glasfiber
dass das beste kabel aber das braucht
halt immer in diamanten und das habe ich
in den habe ich ja nicht deswegen
zurzeit komme ich auch schon mit meinen
mit meinen sachen ganz gut aus in
zukunft wie das dann allerdings keine
alternative da hin wo komme ich an die
wand dieser große raum
zweitens das blaue saphir
das kenne ich nicht das ist dieses
komische zeugs da was man überhaupt
nicht braucht ich hasse das wasser einer
höhle das unnötigste was es gibt aber
eine menge ärzte das gut ok wo sie nennt
vize dies nicht viele ärzte kuba noch
sind schön am boden weisen schöner boden
geblieben was wie ich selbst am leben
ich hoffe ihr wisst dass das alles nur
ironie ist
hauptsache ich sagte zu mir ich bin ein
schöner boden geblieben sind schöne
reisen reisen reisen sollte ich kann ich
nur zu bauen war wieder weg und jetzt
ist meine der mannschaft im moment
kaputt doch nicht hier geht es noch
weiter alter das aber versteckt hier was
bringt mir das bringen wir das hier was
bringt mir diese ganzen charge hier die
hier dieser art ist das nur zum
verzaubern
ja da ist nur zum verzaubern glaube ich
oder wenn wenn wenn das noch zu versüßen
anderen ist ihr wisst ja ne ist der
bescheid freunde habe ich jetzt auch
schon eine menge holz kommt die sonne
raus damit es schön auch draußen sowie
viel habe ich der mittlerweile ich hab
schon fast bis der körper das heißt zwei
speck so das heißt 2 420 durch drei
nutzern sich durch drei sind jetzt
derzeit 40 cable halter das eine menge
da bräuchte noch eine menge ist die
krise aber ich habe an meinem bäumen
waren was dran habe ich schon gesehen
neben bayer leverkusen ja ich habe auf
jeden fall dann schon eine menge
kupferkabel das heißt solarpanel müsste
ich wahrscheinlich in dieser session
noch hinkriegen
ich möchte jetzt allerdings auch wieder
gehen weil ich habe hier keine lust mehr
zweite rumzulaufen das ist also das
kohle einfach und easy peasy so warnt
dieser komische gang neuer dieser
komische raum
bisher wahrt jetpack power
sag es mal wieder draußen
so gehen wir das mal dann fliegen wir es
einfach über nacht zurück
würde ich sagen wenn das überhaupt jetzt
klar geht
scheiße dieser legt er sich auf es ist
nacht jungs es ist nötig dass das wenn
solar helden der sich über tage auflädt
na gut also wenn er das machen will dann
soll er das tun
da unten sind noch so viele schafe
alltäglich ich möchte die ganze rolle
mitnehmen am liebsten dann kann ich mir
das nicht geil ist aus wolle bauen
ich brauche auch richtig viele fäden
noch weil ich möchte mir das möchte ich
mir machen brauche ich allerdings auch
canvas führen das brauche ich find s 8
10 808 64 64 werden sowieso leicht
aufzutreiben worauf ich auf jeden fall
eine menge dasenbrock zum bund
zum glück ich keinen fall schauen welche
dem schon längst open jetpack aktion so
krones immer gold und diamant drin unten
drin allerdings ist das eine falle und
zwar kommt hier am rand irgendwo lava
heraus glaube ich aber dass da oben ihm
bekommt auf jeden fall lava aus
was ich weiß dass es eine falle ist wie
mache ich das leute und ist auch noch
kupfer ich glaub ich glaube mich an der
seite einfach mal runter und dann fliege
ich nachher einfach hoch und bäume dass
man um wieder zu oder irgendwie so ich
weiß nicht auf jeden fall ist eine falle
so viel kann ich euch sagen heißt luca
der fallen forschers und tour am besten
wäre es in der tat wollten könnten
wegschmeißen nachkommen dieser schaufeln
für diese schau weltkriegen kommen hier
ein erdloch
so jetzt geht's ab wie mache ich das
noch mal ganz kurz
hmm
leute ich glaube ich habe mir schon mal
einen kleinen ausweg weil ich möchte
unbedingt diesen diamant blog haben
der ist so wertvoll für mich gewesen
also der der ist einfach wertvoll für
mich ich habe jetzt nicht 36 diamanten
sowie andere leute hier auf dem server
deswegen ist das für mich ganz ganz
wichtig
so ich werde dann einfach gleich schön
hoch jumpen jetzt erstmal diesem tollen
nicht mal inventar welchen abgebaut
hatte er gar nicht aufnehmen können
werd mir gerade sein
ach hier unten ist allerdings der
scheiße jetzt wieder raus stellen locken
ja aber dann wird die falle ausgelöst
limburgs wenn das jetzt immer gesagt hat
so die ganzheitliche um eine falle
rummel so inventar platz ist frei
ab geht's raus hier drei tage wach ja
gut ich glaube da hat sich eh nicht
ausgelöst weil ich den blog direkt
eingesammelt habe
sonst wäre das tor und auf dem bock
drauf gefallen der wir runter gefallen
unter der lava hochbekommen hey diamant
kostenlos kaum je so da hinten ist eine
kiste hey ich glaub da bricht auch alles
zusammen die kiste öffnet fragezeichen
fick dich was will diese scheiße licht
von mir das ist böse das greifen mit
energie an
verpiss dich die nennt sich das nochmal
wissen glaube ich dass wir auch im netz
bahn hat mich angegriffen
vollidiot egal zurück zur stadt wo statt
8000 blöcke ist ja nix alter es waren
spannender trip auf dem ich hier war so
viele schafe die mich am liebsten
einfach alle alten macht das jetzt
wirklich machen jetzt kräftig
selten ernst verpiss dich habe ich ihm
irgendwas getan
das ist doch alles nur durch spark ihre
eingeholt worden diese ganze magie oder
ich will mich jetzt auch möglich schnell
bei allen die mit dem ganzen blablabla
kommt doch gleich wieder an diese blöde
scheiße beteiligt ich fick dich
minecraft auch zwei werke und jetzt
nehme ich euch alle mal ganz kurz mit